I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey everybody! Hello!
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士，大家好！
We are very excited about our new podcast. We are. It starts on October 16th. But we wanted to give you a little sneak peek. Each week we'll break down a new episode of The Office. We're starting at the beginning and going in order. So you can watch along with us. In each episode we will give you what I like to call Fast Facts.
我们对我们的新播客感到非常兴奋。是的，我们很兴奋。它于 10 月 16 日开播。但我们想让你先睹为快。每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集新节目。我们从头开始，按顺序进行。这样你就可以和我们一起观看了。在每一集中，我都会带给你我喜欢称之为“快速事实”的内容。
You do like to call them that. She made it up, folks. She's very proud. I did and I am. So you'll get three Fast Facts and then after the Fast Facts we will go through the episode. And we're going to tell you behind-the-scenes stories. Oh, Jenna, I have one. Okay.
你确实喜欢这样称呼它们。各位，这是她编的。她为此感到很骄傲。我确实编了，而且我也很骄傲。所以你会得到三个快速事实，然后我们会浏览这一集。我们要告诉你幕后故事。哦，珍娜，我有一个。好吧。
Okay, okay. So do you remember Booth's Cruise? Of course. All right. So here's the deal about Booth's Cruise. You guys, these were night shoots. We never did night shoots. That's true.
好吧，好吧。你还记得布斯巡游吗？当然。好吧。关于布斯巡游是这样的。各位，这些都是夜间拍摄。我们从来不拍夜景。确实如此。
We would show up for Booth's Cruise. We had to go to a boat in Long Beach. We had to get there at like 4 p.m. and we filmed till like 5 in the morning. Well one of the fun things was that we all got hotel room. I know! So it was like a big slumber party. Jenna, I have been wanting to ask you this question. I don't know why I've never asked you this question, but did you have to do the puking
我们会去参加布斯巡游。我们必须去长滩的一艘船上。我们必须在下午 4 点左右到达那里，一直拍到凌晨 5 点左右。有趣的事情之一就是我们都订了酒店房间。我懂了！所以这就像是一个大型睡衣派对。珍娜，我一直想问你这个问题。我不知道为什么我从来没有问过你这个问题，但你必须做呕吐
scene? No. What? Yeah. I didn't have to do it. Son of a- I know. I know.
场景吗？没有。什么？是的。我不需要做。真是一个— 我知道。我知道。
A lot of you guys did though, right? Yes. Here's the thing. Greg Daniels thought it'd be really funny if a bunch of people in the episode got seasick. Yes. Yeah. Well a lot of people in real life got seasick. Oh, in real life people were like turning green.
你们很多人都做了，对吧？是的。事情是这样的。格雷格·丹尼尔斯认为如果剧集里的一群人晕船会非常有趣。是的。是的。现实生活中很多人都晕船了。哦，在现实生活中，人们的脸色都变绿了。
Yacking off the side of that boat. I know. It had this like subtle like roll back and forth and people got like, they got like really sick and everyone had those bracelets with the little- Which don't really work. They don't work, you guys. Sorry to ever mix them, but we didn't have success with them. Anyway, so here we are shooting all night long and Greg comes up to me.
在船舷边呕吐。我知道。它有这种微妙的来回晃动，人们真的生病了，每个人都有那些带有小—其实根本不起作用的手镯。各位，它们不起作用。很抱歉把它们混在一起，但我们没有成功。无论如何，我们整晚都在拍摄，格雷格向我走来。
It's like one in the morning. Greg Daniels, our showrunner, creator, and he's like, hey, Angela, will you do some of the puking stuff? Kate Flannery's going to do it. I was like, what? He was just grabbing random people to get puking shots. Yeah. In between scenes, he would take the B camera operator and we would go out on the back of
大约是凌晨一点。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，我们的剧集运作人、创作者，他说，嘿，安吉拉，你能做一些呕吐的东西吗？凯特·弗兰纳里会做的。我当时想，什么？他只是随机抓人来拍呕吐镜头。是的。在场景之间，他会带着 B 摄像机操作员，我们走到
the boat and you had two choices. You could take a big swig of cold Minestrone soup or cold cream of mushroom. What did you pick? Oh, God. It was so disgusting. I took a big swig. Do you have any guesses? I'm guessing you picked Minestrone, that's what I would have picked.
船的后面，你有两个选择。你可以大口喝冷杂菜汤或冷奶油蘑菇汤。你选了哪个？哦，天哪。太恶心了。我大口喝了下去。你有什么猜测吗？我猜你选了杂菜汤，如果是我，我也会选那个。
Yes. That's what I picked. I picked Minestrone. And they said, okay, take a huge, you know, swallow and hold it in your mouth until we say action and on action, spew it out. And I want you to know like the 10 seconds it took them to like get the camera ready, holding that cold soup in my mouth. I literally started to physically gag like, and then I, and then on action they were like
是的。这就是我选的。我选了杂菜汤。他们说，好的，大口吞咽，含在嘴里，直到我们喊“开始”，喊“开始”后，把它吐出来。我想让你知道，他们准备相机大概花了 10 秒钟，嘴里含着冷汤。我真的开始生理性作呕，然后我，在喊“开始”时他们说
spew. And then none of it ended up in the episode. Oh my gosh. And we did like three takes of fake puking off the side of the boat. That's gross. And that is a sneak peek of Office Ladies. You're welcome, everybody. You're welcome.
吐。结果这一集里什么都没有。哦天哪。我们还在船舷边拍了三次假呕吐。真恶心。这就是《办公室女士》的先睹为快。不客气，各位。不客气。
I learned something I didn't know. Well, good. You guys, come hang out with us while we watch the office and, you know, be best friends. Office Ladies premieres October 16th. Subscribe now in Apple Podcasts, Stitcher, or wherever you listen. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我学到了一些我不知道的东西。好吧，很好。大家来和我们一起重温《办公室》，做最好的朋友吧。《办公室女士》将于 10 月 16 日首播。立即在苹果播客、Stitcher 或你收听的任何地方订阅。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。